a government shutdown could affect the
nation's response to the most widespread
flu season in recent years a map from
the Centers for Disease Control and
Prevention shows how this virus has
spread since October so if a funding
bill is not passed the agency will
likely furlough a majority of its staff
including those who monitor this virus
some school districts and Texas have
shut down because of the flu
Omar Villafranca is in Dallas with the
latest on the story Omar good morning
good morning here in Dallas County 38
people have already died from the flu
this season last year at this time there
were no deaths at all
now the children's health system here
has already seen more than 2100
confirmed cases of the flu and that
number is expected to go up for the past
month or so we have been overwhelmed
with a very large number of patients
with flu patients pouring into health
centers nationwide some hospitals are
responding as they would for a major
disaster this triage tent was
constructed outside the emergency room
for California's Loma Linda University
Medical Center we've set up the tent
outside in an attempt to just find a
place to continue to evaluate patients
and treat them at a congressional
hearing on public health threats
confederal health officials stressed the
severity of the flus impact influenza is
probably the greatest natural health
threat we face in Oklahoma the flu has
forced at least half a dozen school
districts to shut down for at least a
day
the virus alone has caused more than 20
deaths and more than a thousand
hospitalizations across the state across
the border in Texas
58 students called out sick Wednesday at
the Shelton School and evaluation center
in Dallas you can use it under the arm
you can use it in your mouth nearly half
of the school's nine hundred twenty
students are using smart thermometers to
record their temperature online the
parents can post anonymously what their
child is feeling if they have a sore
throat if they have flu if they have a
headache
nurse Eve Herrmann says it helps the
school community monitor and limit the
spread of flu outbreaks if the families
know that their child has symptoms of
other children that have the flu they're
more than likely to keep them home
kenza is one of those companies that
makes a smart thermometer and they found
that missouri is the sickest state in
the country about 5.2 percent of the
people there reported sick that's more
than 40,000 people coming down with the
flu virus and it's already killed
already 33 people in the state Norah
boy those numbers really put it in
perspective Omar thank you so much